mais on va plus loin aujourd'hui avec
diane imams directeur du mensuel afrique
magazine bronze ils adorent soir face à
vous dire mes cendres est grand reporter
à france 24 bonjour james les
parlementaires ici en france débattront
donc de l'engagement français au mali
annonce de jean castex le premier
ministre fait face à une opposition qui
en grande partie réclame le départ de la
france après l'expulsion par la junte
malienne de l'ambassadeur français en
poste à bamako ecoutez jean castex
nous devrons faire évoluer notre
dispositif opérationnel pour lutter
contre le terrorisme sujet n'est pas le
mali vous avez parlé du niger d'autres
étapes contre le terrorisme dans cette
zone ainsi le parlement évidemment
mérite d'être parfaitement informée de
cette situation
et oui le gouvernement organisera un
débat sur la base de l'article
50-2 la constitution sur ce sujet
extrêmement important
à l'état qui n'avait d'ailleurs pas
attendu les sénateurs pour remettre en
cause sa présence en disant vouloir
discuter avec ses partenaires européens
du maintien de la force takouba au mali
via l'imam le désengagement se confirme
ou s'accélèrent et b on sait pas trop
partir ou rester c'est pas aussi simple
que ça parce que partir
partir comme ça ça serait à la fois
d'une certaine manière
céder à la pression de la junte de
bamako c'est accepter que l'ambassadeur
soit soit expulsé c'est accepter que
taboo cas soit 6 ans 2 donc on va partir
comme ça et on ne peut pas rester comme
ça donc on est dans un espèce
d'entre-deux d'où je pense ce timing qui
a été créée parce que le fond du
problème c'est la relation franco
malienne mais c'est aussi la présence de
la france sur le sahel c'est la lutte
contre le terrorisme et puis c'est quand
on parle de présence de la france c'est
c'est quand même on est dans le coeur du
pré carré de l'influencé française en
afrique donc c'est quand même un dossier
extrêmement important à deux mois des
élections il ya des mots comme
afghanistan qui circulent dans la presse
des routes des bacs donc on voit à quel
point tout ça est et est complexe et je
pense qu'on va en parler et aussi parce
que cette affaire dépasse le cadre de
bamako c'est une affaire qui maintenant
concerne la menace sécuritaire concerne
maintenant tout un arc de cercle qui va
de l'océan atlantique jusqu'à la mer
rouge et qui descend jusqu'en afrique
centrale donc on n'est plus dans la même
discussion de 2012 2013 avec un ennemi
densifier un état central qui était le
mali là on est sur un front multiples et
donc ça tout a changé donc je pense
qu'il ya besoin d'un peu de temps du
côté français pour réfléchir mais oui et
autour de la france un james on
s'interroge aussi la ministre allemand
des affaires étrangères anna lena
bareback estime à son tour que
l'engagement militaire d europe 1 doit
être réévalué takouba quoi qu'il arrive
et condamnés condamné il faut voir tech
loba et menacé ça c'est une évidence
c'est une évidence parce que le danemark
a décidé de se retirer parce que la
norvège la demande à la demande et la
demande de le jouer tout à fait à la
demande de la junte il avait 90 soldats
qui était arrivé quelques jours
auparavant des forces spéciales des
chirurgiens militaires eh bien ils ont
plié bagage il y avait la norvège qui
devait envoyer un contingent qui n'a pas
réussi à aller au bout de ses
négociations bilatérales avec la junte
et qui a décidé là aussi de renoncer et
puis à la suède qui avait 150 hommes
depuis février 2020 qui arrive au bout
de son engagement et qui annonce
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne souhaite pas
continuer vous parlez de l'allemagne
l'allemagne c'est un engagement
légèrement différent c'est pas ta coups
bas c'est la minus main donc c'est la
force de l'onu et c'est le utm qui est
donc l'unité de formation qui est là
pour aider les femmes à les forces
armées maliennes le utm iac représente 3
128 soldats allemands le l'onu ça
représente 11 170 soldats est
effectivement leur mandat se termine fin
mai avec cette question vont-ils
renouvelé alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que au bundestag c'est quelque
chose qui fait réellement débat avec une
opposition qui dit mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait là bas pourquoi on reste là bas
avec des questions avec christine
lambrecht qui est la ministre de la
défense qui avait dit le 22 janvier on
reste quoi qu'il arrive on va pas se
laisser impressionner et là on a
l'impression que ça tangue et que c'est
pas tout à fait le même le même point
sachant que c'est quand même vraiment un
projet important pour la france et
c'était le laboratoire de l'europe de la
défense vouloir rester pour pacifier le
mali et restaurer le processus électoral
y compris contre la volonté exprimée par
une partie du peuple malien lui même
dans la rue dans son soutien à la jeune
c'est c'est une erreur de la part des
français du lait du néocolonialisme on
l'entend ici non mais il ya une question
et au colonialisme excusez-moi 50 ou 60
ans après les indépendances je pense
qu'il faut aussi sortir de ce prisme il
ya bien une problématique malienne ça
c'est très clair il ya une junte qui a
décidé de rester de s'installer qui a
changé le calendrier qui était prévu qui
a décidé de rester cinq ans et c'est pas
que la france qui est impliqué les états
de l'ue et moi les états de la cedeao
les sanctions elles sont elles sont
globales donc c'est pas la france
elle-même la france elle est venue en
2012 2013 pour soutenir un pays qui
était exempt gay qu'allait être envahi
par des forces djihadistes à la demande
de bamako à la demande de barack o 2 je
pense que aujourd'hui la donne est
changée à bamako que la france certes
encore une fois avoir des soldats
français dans les cas qui français des
drapeaux bleu blanc rouge ça fait pas
toujours plaisir c'est c'est clair dans
le paysage c'est difficile mais quelle
est l'alternative aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on pense que sincèrement les wagner
les mercenaires russes vont pouvoir
tenir ça vous parliez de l'europe tout à
l'heure mais l'entrée de la russie dans
le jeu c'est aussi un facteur de ré
implication des européens parce que d'un
seul coup il y avait il y avait un
danger sécuritaire clairement parce
qu'ils le sentent les européens ils
sentent bien que la france est la
première porte mais qu'une fois que ça
rentre dans france soir en allemagne ça
peut en italie ce qu'elle est partout
donc ils sont conscients de ça et ils
ont maintenant conscience que des
joueurs plus aventuriers
et à ses prédateurs sont en train de
s'installer et donc c'est pas je pense
que ramener la discussion à france
néocoloniale c'est un peu être dans le
jeu d'une partie de l'élite politique de
ces pays qui a besoin de boucs
émissaires mais je dire la vraie
question aujourd'hui au mali et au
burkina c'est déjà la capacité
institutionnelle de ces pays à se
défendre à s'organiser politiquement on
peut pas croire que des militaires qui
ont déjà fait 27 ou d'état ou 35 coups
d'état ont une solution elle s est
pourtant au nom de l'efficace la mecque
une partie de l'arrière et soutiennent
la revue fondée non dans la lutte contre
les deals partie des maliens soutiennent
la junte parce que une partie de la
classe politique nous fait croire que
c'est la faute des soldats français si
tout va maintenant si tous y beaucoup de
choses vont mal c'est aussi la faute des
institutions et si les militaires était
capable de refonder ce qu'ils avaient
déjà dit en
2012-13 enfin bref 14 cas il aurait
refonder donc on voit bien que c'est une
crise multidimensionnelle où la france a
une part à jouer mais si on imagine que
la france l'union européenne à buca les
américains se retirent qui va défendre
ces pays contre contre leurs ennemis qui
est là dans le désert un sentiment anti
français qu'on a vu s'exprimer un james
au burkina faso et au niger sa
contrarien d'éventuels redéploiements
des forces françaises hors du mali dans
cette zone dite des trois frontières
alors je pense qu'il faut il faut faire
très attention avec ces différentes
crises qui sont différentes c'est à dire
qu'on a effectivement au mali quelque
part une jeune qui est dans une fuite en
avant qui est en difficulté qui se
trouve sanctionné par la cedeao j'étais
la balle les dix jours on a fait un
reportage sur un marché les gens voient
les prix explosent et les marches c'est
notamment à cause des marchands qui sont
en train de faire grimper les prix on
arrive en période de ramadan les
familles sont inquiètes et donc la junte
donne le change en disant voilà tout ça
c'est l'intérieur disant c'est senna
país mais des militaires français pris
pour cible par la rue on ne le voit pas
comme a dit non alors après
effectivement si on prend le burkina le
burkina c'est encore autre chose au
burkina c'est je pense un coup d'état
qui est beaucoup plus liées à l'armée
elle même parce qu'en fait ce qui a
choqué ses 53 soldats qui ont été
massacrés par les djihadistes alors
qu'ils avaient plus de ravitaillement et
ça c'est quelque chose qui a eu un
impact sur l'opinion publique et sur
l'armée elle-même qui s'est élevé en 10
ans et coûteux pas continuer à
travailler dans des conditions pareilles
je pense qu'il ya certes de sentiments
anti-français qui est là mais il ya une
vraie menace djihadiste ya une vraie
constate l'incapacité du pouvoir à
régler le problème d'un pays qu'il faut
le rappeler en plus les prix dans son
rythme entre les djihadistes du sahel et
boko haram donc on est dans une
situation très tendue là bas et je pense
que là on à l'armée qui est vraiment
sorti de ses gonds quelque part soutenu
aussi par la russe que maintenant on a
ce soutien populaire mais il ya quand
même ça clairement le redéploiement
français n'est pas menacé par ce
sentiment qu'on a vu s'exprimer au
nigeria l'imam je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion
il ya une réflexion sur comment
réorganiser je pense le bleu le format
et je ne vois pas comment la france et
l'europe est derrière quand même malgré
tout les états unis qui apportent de qui
apporte d'autres soutiens les satellites
les écoute extérieurs je vois commence
tout ça va déserter ce terrain c'est à
dire c'est clair combat je vois pas où
ça va partir et puis il faut pas oublier
aussi l'importance et la présence et l
influence des pays côtiers que ce soit
le la côte d'ivoire que ce soit la
mauritanie que ce soit le sénégal que ce
soit le bénin que ça soit le togo qui
vont pas dire ah mais oui bien sûr que
tout le monde s'en aille comme ça on
sera en première ligne tout ça c'est
tout ça c'est une succession de deux
cubes qui doivent sans boiter et dans un
contexte encore une fois où la ligne de
front n'est plus uniquement sur la zone
j'allais dire qui va de la mauritanie
jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à niamey mais qui
est maintenant une zone de feront
éclater c'est à dire il y à des attaques
jusqu'au mozambique qui se passe si on
se rend compte jusqu en rd congo donc la
zone a éclaté le danger est là il ya un
problème clair et net j'allais dire
bilatérales maintenant entre la france
et le mali donc il va se résoudre d'une
manière ou d'une autre après vous
parliez des difficultés économiques cl
faut quand même prendre un sacré risque
aujourd'hui pour s'isoler complètement
puisque les sanctions ils seront pas au
sommeil
afrique ils vont être sanctionnés
peut-être par les milieux européens dont
il ya quand même une forme
d'inconscience de fuite en avant il ya
un pari quand même très stupéfiant que
encore une fois des milices comme tim
wagner où ça va leur permettre d'être en
espèces d'autarcie et puis on en parle
et je crois la semaine dernière il me
semble
tous ces pays sont imbriqués il a une
population malienne en côte d'ivoire qui
est très importante les enfants des
pontes et des notes des notables maliens
vont à l'école à abidjan et ils vont à
l'université là bas et l'argent malien
est à abidjan vous allez à marcory oui
des tours qui pousse son discours dit
c'est l'argent du mali donc tout ça ne
peut pas rester dans cette danse est
apte à de morcellement donc il y aura
forcément à un moment quelque chose qui
va se regrouper et la france là où c'est
difficile c'est qu'elle a été pendant
très longtemps le centre du jeu
aujourd'hui elle est un des acteurs du
jeu et elle doit apprendre à composer et
ça après on pourrait parler d'un certain
nombre d'erreurs du maquereau nisme
nouveau sur la foule sur l'afrique
d'aujourd'hui le sommet de montpellier
le bail passing des chefs d'état en
période de crise peut-être ce n'était
pas la meilleure idée mais mais voilà il
faut redresser au populaire hausse à la
société si c'est très bien de s'adresser
à l'aspect civil mais il faut aussi
s'adresser aux gens qui sont en charge
qui ont les manettes qui qui ont les
outils james andré oui non cette fuite
en avant et les réels c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ils y apprennent
d'argent qui va se poser très rapidement
parce que c'est les sanctions
financières sont très lourdes voir que
la france aussi est en train de couper
les robinets on est en train de fermer
beaucoup de beaucoup d' aide à l'état
beaucoup d' aide au développement pour
l'instant la position c on continue les
projets de développement qui sont en
cours mais on en lance pas nouveau vous
avez également des bailleurs de fonds
internationaux qui coupent les vannes
lab la junte va se retrouver
financièrement à se fixer à dire juste
un mollet burkina les militaires
burkinabés ont une approche complètement
enfin comme vous le faisiez celle semble
être un règlement pour franchement
militaire pour le coup même si encore
une fois je pense qu'il faut condamner à
six économies a beaucoup de mai mais ils
ont ouvert des portes ils ont rétabli
alors bizarrement la constitution donc
soit trop comment tout ça va marcher ils
ont d une garde de ne pas aller trop
loin oui parce que parce qu'ils ont ils
ont la sensation que l' isolement serait
la pire de l'heure la pire des
situations sont plus sur un modèle
guinéens que que magna magna mans en
tout cas la france on l'a bien vu elle
est prise entre plusieurs feux dans
cette région au sud du sel en proie aux
mouvements djihadistes et au coup d'état
dernier en date il a échoué c'est en
guinée-bissau où six militaires ont tout
de même trouvé la mort dans des combats
avec des assaillants qui voulaient s'en
prendre au palais présidentiel en plein
conseil des ministres un coût des
narcotrafiquants estime le chef de
l'état a écouté ce ne sont pas seulement
les militaires qui sont impliqués mais
c'est surtout la lutte contre le trafic
de drogue qui en est à l'origine parce
que la plupart des personnes impliquées
sont des personnes inscrites sur la
liste d' enquête anti drogue
un président qui s'estime visée pour
avoir voulu lutter contre le trafic de
drogue et la corruption trafic de la
cocaïne a notamment dont la guinée
bissau est une plaque tournante entre
l'amérique latine et l'europe via de
l'imam c'est une donnée propre
finalement à cette crise qui est
différent des autres enfin on n'a pas
tous les éléments là c'est un petit peu
en tous les cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
la guinée bissau est un de ces fameux
marcos tête des plaques des plaques
tournantes après il ya un problème
institutionnel très clair puisqu'il ya
une élection qui est contesté depuis
déjà plusieurs mois donc on voit bien
que souvent dans ces crises c'est à la
fois mélange d'une situation
structurelle d'une situation ponctuelle
souvent politique et que tant que tous
ces éléments fonctionnent ensemble on va
droit vers ce genre de situation mais
bon là les coups d'état en guinée bissau
il y en a eu certains nombres un ses
seize devaient pas les chiffres exacts
donc non ces 16 + 4 qui ont réussi 16
raté quatre réussit donc on en a 20 ans
bat depuis l'indépendance du portugal je
pense que pour être honnête qu'on est 76
75 en
tout cas effectivement oui il est
possible qu'il y ait un impact de
nombreux trafiquants est impossible
également qu' il y ait un problème avec
l'armée parce qu'il faut savoir juste la
veille du coup d'état il ya en général
très important qui était très proche du
président et qui tenait l'armé inquiète
qui est décédé bah voilà et puis
effectivement je pense qu'on est quand
même dans une problématique légèrement
différente même si une fois de plus
quand on prend une carte et qu'on
regarde on se re on se rend compte
qu'une espèce de ceinture la deux de
peau de putsch avec un seul trou au
milieu d'ailleurs c'est le niger qui est
largement préoccupante et le week-end
dernier il y avait des élections au
sénégal sont parfaitement bien passé qui
était même assez qu'on disputait donc ce
que je dis quand on regarde la carte
elle et elle et elle est inquiétante
mais les trucs complètement un peu
trompeuse au sel non elle est
diversifiée bonne foi l'afrique c'est
chaque chaque pays et a une histoire
merci de le rappeler dia l'imam c'était
on va plus loin par moments on est
toujours dans pareil direct c'est pour
ça que j'ai eu une hésitation merci
également à james andré d'avoir été avec
nous